hi there I'm going to try to explain
this story in 60 seconds but it's a bit
of a doozy so no promises I'm gonna be
able to do it okay
okay so mark jacoba Ella Rihanna and
Mitchell Trump all left behind the bank
cards and passports and their cell
phones at the Berry Farm in Melbourne
and drove 825 kilometres north now one
by one the family members started to
lead the road trip Mitchell is first he
said he felt uneasy and took a bunch of
trains back to Melbourne and just kind
of left the family there then Elinor on
over the next week Rihanna was found
catatonic in the back of a ginger truck
and Ella apparently stole a car and then
drove it home next mark was spotted by
two Pokemon go players in a park and
they claimed that he was stalking them
the cops got called the cops chased
around for a while and then last
Thursday for at four hours north of that
Jacoby was found disoriented wandering
the streets of a town called yes now the
family can't explain what happened and
we reporters tried to ask the dead mark
about what happened he basically flipped
everybody off the apologize a couple
days later basically saying the family
doesn't feel very well right now
obviously now like I said there's no
real answer for why any of this happened
but one of the most popular theories
online is that maybe the family was
exposed to rotten berries on their berry
farm and it made them all go a little
crazy but I think the truth is probably
out there somewhere so Q x-files theme
music because I don't know
[Music]